wait jar jar then everyone had to say
sorry everyone had to say sorry
that was really good really good that
was very good I really hated what you
just did
[Music]
so there's a little bit of controversy
that just took the Internet by a storm
and but JK has not yet
um weighed in on this topic oh no it is
Margot Robbie mid
really who says that who started that on
the internet what does mid mean yeah
like man you tell me Bart like she's
she's just average like she ain't all
that yeah I think she's one of the
hottest chicks that ever lived yeah so
she's starting in the Barbie movie right
yeah and there's hella people on Twitter
being like she's mid who gives a [__] I
think that's a good one what height are
they trying to [__] on her you know what
it is though let's look at the guy like
the guys pictures that are judging you
guys don't understand this you
understand this tragedy okay this is a
very strong strategy you use to get
other women to be like oh my God that
guy is cool as hell I was explaining
this to you yesterday remember yeah
right whenever there's a hottie Walking
In You Gotta nag her immediately say she
said I'll go and you gotta find
something that's wrong something that
like oh dude your your hairline's too
straight you're a [__] Ugo and then
everyone is like oh my God Nick is so
cool and then you walk away with your
oversized Top Hat a little tilted that's
really good advice
so you put that on Twitter and then
other people read your tweets and they
go holy [__] man because like that it's
like a different guy
private account zero post hey profile
picture
I don't even know where the origin it
came from because it went so crazy like
everyone was talking about it on Twitter
oh my God yeah it was wild how do you
like it's so weird like it's not like
she just came out either yeah like she's
had so many good accomplishments under
her belt already I don't think
uh Hot For This generation I think of
all time like if he took all of like the
80s 90s 70s 60s 50s like the most the
like who are like the beauty queens I
think she's up there with them the thing
for me too is that so when she came out
Wolf of Wall Street for most people she
was hot that's like she was a very she
was a very big deal okay so she can play
an alluring character and then you see
her in the [__] Tonya Harding movie
yeah and you're like okay the skill now
and the range Marilyn Monroe never had a
role like that yeah nope I never saw
Marilyn Monroe's butthole tell you that
nope I've seen Margot Robbie's butthole
big time she has a butthole scene in
Wolf of Wall Street really were you
watching the same movie Ryan it wasn't
you see her [__] in butthole is this a
director's cut yeah
I heard that orgy scene smelled like
[__] really like the one on the plane
everybody that was [__] it smelled
like [__] I mean there's they did it in
the office in a mansion on a plane well
that's what I heard
that's just what it is all day it just
smelled like [__] everywhere
you got that just keep saying it dude I
don't give a [__] the rest of this video
I don't give a [__] you just keep saying
that disgusting wait did you actually
hear that yeah from who from the guys
that were working on set do they know
why oh it sounds like so hot and I mean
it looks like it's so hot but in the
reality was he had to do so many takes
it was hot as [__] everyone was naked it
smelled like [__]
the reality is never like the facade of
film right that is why because movie
Magic it is Magic
I can't get the smells [__] smell out I
wish there was like a behind the scenes
Wall Street and it cuts to Joe and it
says his little his little in the lower
third it says JoJo or whatever a
producer and then he's like it smells
like [__]
like like the aliens guy going like this
he's just he's like in front of a
bookcase and he's just very better in
fact like yeah it's about like
people don't know this people think it
was a very lavish scene but a lot of
people were asking me Joe it was like to
shoot the origin scene I had to tell
them it smelled like [__] the whole time
and it keeps cutting yeah it keeps
cutting back and forth from people
saying they had a great experience we
worked hard we did a lot we accomplished
it smelled like [__] absolute [__]
caca they had like Christopher Nolan in
there and he's like he's like this
beautiful movie obviously so many
pastiches and those
and [__] Joe in there my [__]
I smell like [__]
you'll wash your ass before you come to
[__] do a sex scene what's where's
your professionalism I mean if you're
doing multiple takes of that thing I
mean you're probably sweating so much
more than they need a sponsorship from
Lumi dude yeah that's one of our
sponsors what is it it's a [__]
deodorant whole body deodorant designed
by a gynecologist it's paraben free and
you can [__] rub your nuts your [__]
everywhere on their whole body yeah that
would have helped that scene hell yeah
brought to you by Loom
what a [__] brand ambassador
sponsor's like that's not in the copy
the CEO was like get me this man
no he's recusing himself going that's
your CEO he's like of course you can rub
it Underpants
that's such a good copy this guy's
innovating
you want this you can rub it on your
[__] what
consumer who's like I need that yep
right hey dude and you can hustle it
you're in the grocery store parking lot
or something like that you're hustling
with a bunch of Lumi and you're like hey
you can rub this on your [__] chase
women down and you can rub it on your
[__] yeah hey swimming device more good
advice I know exactly where it would
sell Figueroa oh no
they're they're like oh thank you I've
been looking for something to freshen up
in between my jobs biggest problem with
Figaroa too have you smelled it down
there
it actually doesn't smell like [__] it
doesn't smell like [__] not unless you
get close to people that smell like [__]
oh yeah that's true Pro tip for you yeah
stay away if you gotta get closer
I mean I guess you know what this is an
indication of though it's like every
time someone gets enough ground and
reaches a certain height that's almost
like she's not fat
this confirmation that
you like is there is there a standard
like Kim Kardashian and they're like
she's the hottest you know you know
who's hot Shannon sauceman because she
never reached a height that it was like
common to say that who Shannon I don't
even know who that is it's awesome man
well that's see see how deep cut baby
familiar yeah she you know like all the
people that were hot in our high school
day it's like they were is she in like
the teen chick flicks that when we're in
the 90s or like really old school
saucepan sausage
Shannon are you looking at her now I
don't know bro oh she has black hair
mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah
Shannon's awesome man huh
what's that movie
what does she look like
Sarah Silverman's sister bang bang
nightstand I think she's kind of mid oh
she's she's uh let me see she's a nice
she's the main girl Knight's Tale
I mean if you're looking at her now from
her now me and Colleen think she's good
yeah well that's what is that that's her
now though that's right that's her Demi
Moore has the same look as she looks
better like her her impact in the 90s
like it was different I think yeah I was
like Demi Moore looks similar and she's
better Demi Moore right she has a
similar look mint yep
so I think you have to compare similar
looks to similar looks but there are
people that are just haters like any a
song or a food or anything gets too
popular they just have to [__] on it
yeah it's easier to do that it's not
about having a correct opinion just
about having an opinion that's visible
and if you're the one guy disagreeing
then your shit's standing out and people
just like no she sucks or even when the
whole world came together if you guys
remember there's two times in my life
when the whole world came together it
was 9 11.
and when Rebecca Black came out with her
music video It's Friday did the Middle
East come together with us about 9 11.
no no no like American America did
yeah
does the old world come together about
something when Rebecca Black's video
came out everybody united we were stood
hand in hand and shoulder to shoulder
and we're all like this sucks yeah this
12 year old girl sucks she sucks and
she's probably a [__] yeah and geez
that was the I tweeted that there's a
lot of anonymous comments saying that
too yeah I remember reading but but then
it's sad to think that now people get
[__] on for uniting back then because
we're like man that video sucked and
then now it's like she's like hey did
you know that that hurt my feelings and
then we're all like oh man
yeah man it undoes all of the hard work
yep Jar Jar Binks we were all United the
world standing shoulder shorter I was I
was hugging strangers I was like I hate
Georgia
everybody likes jar jar but then the guy
got really depressed I know he almost
killed himself yeah wait jar jar and
everyone had to say sorry everyone had
to say sorry yeah
he got suicide that was really good
really good that was very good I really
hated what you just did
I like them
yeah big time oh that's like Joffrey
would you watch a jar jar big spin-off
movie yeah but Joffrey was meant to be
[__] hated but everyone did come back
in real life though no but in real life
people will throw tomatoes and [__] at
him and I think he just quit acting he's
like what the [__] I killed it so hard
out of character you actually hate me in
real life yeah that's true yeah but Jar
Jar Binks was meant to be the cute one
is that true that captures the hearts
the people hate him for some reason I
don't know why I thought he was meant to
be like a CGI Flex he was supposed to be
funny he wasn't funny he's the comic
yeah why do people hate us he's like
he's like Waldo from Family Matters he's
like supposed to be like Groot
oh yeah oh my God
so they try to [__] up the real groom he
whoops her ass yeah
I love good actually yeah Georgia
accidentally wiped out an army that was
pretty cool oh yeah that's right
did you ever buy any jar jar merch
nope I'm not a Star Wars like that
he's a Thor's fan yeah
I'm not a star yeah what isn't that sad
I'm not a Star Wars fan
that's what I heard so I think
everyone's United right now and saying
Margot Robbie is not mid right nah I
think people are just being annoying I
mean she's she's the standard right now
I guess if anything I can get above
average but there's nothing mid and
average about her no she's accomplished
an accomplice she's accomplished she
probably wasn't she has a nice body she
has a pretty face she's her skill set's
insane Yeah clean butthole yeah it
depends even if she's dirty it doesn't
take her [__] points down if somebody
says like oh she's mid and then they
cite a source of like and this person is
actually better than her then I would be
like let's see yeah yeah but those
people never actually have some sort of
comparison or you know or they have like
oh here's here's my life this is the
reason why I see her as men yeah then I
will go oh yeah it's like oh you date
nothing but supermodels
wow but even then so your standards
different she probably could be just to
be a model like in a different alternate
timeline like but as far as just an
actor she's she's [__] very good at
what she does and I wouldn't I wouldn't
speak on it that hard if I didn't see
the Tonya Hardy movie then I was like I
was sold on that being like I wanted to
see that movie because I think Talent
brings you beyond mid even if you're
just like a good looking person like or
even even hearing her and wolf on Wall
Street like her crazy ass East Coast
accent and then hearing her in
interviews yeah and you're like oh [__]
that's crazy she put that on so good
yeah cause you guys get horny off of
talent I don't I just like look at girls
looks and based on that so Margot Robbie
is still above average that's good yeah
yeah I like the time and Harmony that I
wanted to see your boobs real bad
it's kind of kind of a bummer I'm in the
Joe Zone I think there's a yeah I think
there's like to be honest there's way
more only fans girls that probably look
better than Margot Robbie but then still
like because she's just put on a
pedestal people think she's super hot
yeah I think there's a nip slip in the
bloopers of Tanya oh really no what's
the time stamp
[Music]
laughs